what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
so for this week's installment of our
vs. series we're going to switch things
up and try something a little bit
different instead of pitting two
characters against each other we're
going to look at two teams and decide a
winner and the battle we're going to be
looking at today is the DC rebirth Teen
Titans versus the all-new all-different
Avengers and so in order to determine a
winner we have to begin by explaining
the members of each team as well as
their powers and abilities starting with
the Teen Titans
so the DC rebirth version of the Teen
Titans Vegas debut earlier this year as
part of DC's relaunch of most of his
titles and is led by Damian Wayne who's
also the current Robin in the DC
Universe as well as the son of Bruce
Wayne and Talia al Ghul now like all the
Robins Damian has no superpowers but he
is an expert fighter due to his
extensive training that he's received
since birth from his grandfather Ra's al
Ghul and his League of Assassins and
later by his father Bruce Wayne and Dick
Grayson now in addition to being an
expert fighter Damian is also a highly
skilled Acrobat and escaped ologist but
his greatest asset is as access to
Batman's extensive arsenal of weapons
and technology many of which allow him
to augment his physical abilities so
that he could stay at tau to toe with
super-powered opponents now next up on
the team Titans roster is Starfire and
she's a member of an alien race known as
at a moraine ian's and is able to absorb
ultraviolet radiation and converted to
pure energy enabling her to fly as well
as imbue her with superhuman strength
and durability it's also important to
know that she can release the energy she
absorbs as powerful bursts of energy
known as star bolts and can even store
energy and release it all at once in a
devastating blast that travels in all
directions
now the next member of the Teen Titans
is Kid Flash also known as the new 52
Wally West
now Kid Flash like all speedsters in the
DC Universe is able to access the Speed
Force and derive the ability to travel
as super speeds the problem with this is
that right now in DC rebirth he's still
getting his powers sorted out so he's
not nearly on the same level as Barry
Allen or the pre new 52 Wally West now
Raven is perhaps the most powerful
member of the team and is the half human
half demon daughter of Trigon she's also
an empath
meaning she can detect and influence the
emotions of those around her and she can
also heal others by absorbing their pain
and possesses an ability to generate and
control darkness itself and is even able
to project a giant Raven made from pure
darkness furthermore she also possesses
the powers of telepathy telekinesis
hypnosis and teleportation
now rounding out the
teen titans roster is Beast Boy who has
the ability to instantly transform into
any animals these ever seen either in
real life or in a photo or illustration
including animals that are extinct like
dinosaurs in addition to taking the form
of these animals he also takes on the
physical attributes such as their
strength or ability to fly and even
breathe underwater then in addition to
this he also has a fairly advanced
healing factor going so far as being
able to regenerate limbs and so now that
we've gone over the Teen Titans I want
to turn our attention to all-new
all-different Avengers now this version
of The Avengers was put together by Mark
Waid following 2015 secret Wars event
which sought to offer a fresh take on
many of Marvel's teams to that end wade
paired several established members of
the Avengers together with a host of
younger heroes joining the team for the
first time starting with the traditional
members of the team we first come with
Ironman now I'm going to assume that
you've watched my channel enough to know
that you know who Iron Man is but if you
don't there will be a couple of videos
down in the description but I think it's
also important to run over him pretty
quickly
basically Iron Man has no super powers
but it uses his genius level
intelligence and massive bank account to
build suits of armor that allow him to
fly and fire repulsor blasts as well as
take on a multitude of some of Marvel's
most powerful beings now following this
is Thor but it needs to be noted that
we're not talking about the traditional
Thor Odinson
instead we're talking about Jane Foster
who's taking up the mantle of Thor after
she was able to left owning such a
hammer Mounier after he was found
unworthy following Jason
Aaron's original cinnamon now while she
does wield a hammer Jane possesses all
the same abilities that Odin's son
derive from you linear which includes
superhuman strength that allows her to
lift an excess of 100 tons flight
superhuman speed and durability and
advanced healing factor and the ability
to summon and command lightning also on
the Avengers as Captain America
Sam Wilson previously known as the
Falcon now like Iron Man Sam Wilson does
not possess any superpowers that would
help him here and I say that because the
only power he does possess is an
empathic link with birds that allows him
to see through their eyes in addition to
this he is skilled in martial arts and
is at peak physical condition and he's
afforded the ability to fly by a set of
mechanical wings and is also a
possession of Captain America's
vibranium shield which he can use
offensively or defensively now rounding
out the veteran Avengers is the vision
and the vision is a synthezoid or
synthetic humanoid and is probably the
most powerful member of the Avengers
lineup if not one of the most powerful
Avengers and Marvel or
in addition to superhuman strength speed
durability and flight vision is able to
manipulate his density and make himself
intangible or incredibly dense
furthermore he can absorb solar energy
to the solar Joule on his forehead and
can expel it as a powerful destructive
blast now as we said earlier there are
several new members of the Avengers and
the first one we'll go with is Miss
Marvel or Kamala Khan now due to her
inhuman heritage
Kamala was bestowed with powers due to
her exposure to the Terrigen mists now
her powers consists of an ability to
stretch compress or distort her limbs to
basically any shape she can imagine and
change her size from a few inches tall
to the height of a building and she also
has a healing factor although she must
revert to her normal dimensions while
healing and healing also leaves her
tired and hungry following this we come
to Spider Man Miles Morales now miles
has very similar powers to the Peter
Parker version of spider-man which has
enhanced strength and agility ability to
climb walls and spider ships that can
alert him of impending danger although
his spider sense is not as strong as
Peter Parker's in addition to this Miles
has some powers that Peter does not such
as the ability to camouflage himself by
blending it with his surroundings a
venom sting capable of paralyzing any
money touches and a more powerful
version of the venom sting called the
venom blast which could only be used
after significant time to recharge now
moving on to Sam Alexander who's the
newest version of Noah in Marvel Comics
he's also on the Avengers roster and Sam
gets all his abilities from his Nova
helmet which includes the power of
flight superhuman strength speed and
durability and the ability to use a nova
force as a shield or a powerful blast of
energy and finally we had the all-new
all-different wasp Nadya Pym now Nadya
is the daughter of Hank Pym and is a
possession of one of ant-man suits which
allows her to shrink in size while
retaining her normal mass and strength
in addition to this that she has
genius-level intelligence and received
martial arts training from the Red Room
which is the same organization that
trained etosha Romanov the Black Widow
and so now that we've finally gone over
the rosters of each team we can look at
who would win in a battle now you may
have noticed that the scales seem to be
tipped in favor of the Avengers already
since their roster contains eight
members as opposed to the five members
that make up the Teen Titans and so what
we're gonna do here is we're going to
even size up just a little bit in my
opinion the strongest characters in the
battle are Thor and vision so we're
going to take them off the board and
we'll just say Thor is unavailable
because he's dealing with bigger threats
in Asgard and vision is taking care of
his creepy robot family now well it
might not seem
fare to take away the two strongest
members of one team I think most people
would concede that the Teen Titans would
not match up in a fair fight with an
Avengers roster that had Thor and vision
and we want to keep things interesting
so will concede that both rosters are at
full power and the Avengers get the
victory however this still leaves the
Avengers with a one person advantage so
we're going to remove Iron Man for the
playing field and the reason for this is
that I think what's most intriguing
about this battle is that it contains so
many young heroes from both the DC and
Marvel Universe's so I want to preserve
as much of that dynamic as possible and
so we'll just say the Tony Stark's
business obligations are keeping him
from participating and this also leaves
Captain America on the team which is
going to give the young team some
valuable leadership due to his military
background and user experience as a
superhero and so now that we have all
that out of the way we can finally
answer the question of who would win in
a battle between the young heroes of
each team now with that stipulation in
place I think that there are several
areas where the teams match up in
interesting ways for instance I think
Sam Wilson and Damian Wayne are both
strong leaders however I think that
despite his young age I'd actually give
the fighting advantage to Damian due to
his extensive training by the League of
Assassins as well as Bruce Wayne Nova
and Starfire also match up pretty well
as both are flying characters that rely
on energy projection for offense and I
think the battle basically results in a
tie now with that said I think the two
real X factors that push this battle in
favor of the Teen Titans are Raven and
Kid Flash in truth there is simply no
one on the Avengers side that can
account for their power sets the only
avenger that could even come close to
matching Kid Flash's speed would be
vision and that proposal is arguable at
best but it doesn't matter since we've
taken them off the board this presents a
huge problem of the Avengers as Kid
Flash would basically be unstoppable
furthermore Raven is able to use control
of shadows to actually remove people
from the battlefield which the Avengers
really don't have an answer for and so
unless the Avengers are able to take
Raven and Kid Flash out quickly which I
really don't see happening due to their
durability and healing I think that
those two characters are too powerful
for the Avengers to defeat and so that's
basically how I see this fight playing
out you give the Avengers a full roster
and they will win due both to the
superior numbers as well as a fact do
they have two of the strongest
characters on the board in vision and
Thor however if we narrow the scope of
the battle to the young heroes I think
we have to give the victory to the Teen
Titans but with that being said I'm kind
of curious to see what you - thing
because I have no doubt this is going to
inspire all
to debate I'm sure some people will
complain that we took away a couple
members of the Avengers and they would
rather see a team of eight versus five
but I think it was more important to
even the playing field and have five
versus five so again let me know down in
the description cuz I'm kind of curious
I want to know who do you guys think
would win in a battle between the Teen
Titans and the all-new all-different
Avengers also if you guys have
suggestions on future videos for battles
between Marvel DC or marvel an image or
whatever the case may be then let me
know down in the comments section
because I'm actually pretty curious to
see what you won't have if you're new
here to comments explain it make sure
you guys hit the sub button become part
of the Rob core as you guys enjoy this
video drop a like and yeah I will catch
you all later peace
[Applause]
[Music]